in Prag genießen Sie die Herbsttage die
Altstadt ist voller Touristen eine
friedliche Kulisse für einen Gipfel der
von Krisen geprägt ist von Angriffen zu
Land und zur See
es sind diese Bilder die die Gefahr
unter Wasser ins Bewusstsein der
Menschen gebrannt haben der Krieg wird
nicht nur in der Luft zu Land sondern
auch in den Tiefen des Meeres geführt
der Angriff hat Europa wachgerüttelt
wenn uns jemand gesagt hätte dass wir
eine Explosion an den
nordstream-pipelines haben hätten wir
gesagt ach komm
aber jetzt ist dies die neue Realität
ich hoffe nur wie schützt sich Europa
und der Westen konsequent und robust
soll die Antwort auf den Angriff sein
sagt die EU und die NATO aber der Krieg
unter Wasser hinterlässt kaum
täterspuren
unter Wasser ist es viel schwieriger den
Angriff zu identifizieren deshalb sind
diese Angriffe so gefährlich und
effizient
seit Jahren rüsten die Weltmächte am
Meeresboden auf es gibt auch hier das
Duell USA gegen Russland moskau ist
gerade unter Wasser eine macht das Land
besitzt unbemannte unterwasserdrohnen
die viele Kilometer tief tauchen können
am Meeresboden liegen die Lebensadern
der vernetzten Welt
Versorgungskabel für Internet stromdaten
Rohstoffe wenn sie zerstört werden ist
unser tägliches Leben bedroht
wenn ein Angreifer wirklich fest
entschlossen ist dann wird er einen
Schwachpunkt finden vor allem wenn ihm
die Konsequenzen egal sind oder wenn es
ihm nur wichtiger ist den Feind härter
zu treffen als sich selbst es gibt keine
absolute Sicherheit
Europas Infrastruktur ist verwundbar und
damit wächst die Angst deshalb haben die
nationalen Regierungen ihre Kontrollen
auf und unter See verstärkt auch auf dem
EU-Gipfel in Prag wollen Sie über ein
Sicherheitskonzept nachdenken am Ende
wird es auch um mehr Geld für Waffen
gehen aber alles beginnt mit einer
Bestandsaufnahme
Tests werden zeigen ob die
schutzinstrumente ausreichen und wer
genug Mittel besitzen um solche Vorfälle
zu verhindern
solche Vorfälle eine diplomatische
Umschreibung für die Schlacht in der
Tiefe der Gipfel muss eine Antwort
finden für die Zeitenwende die auch am
Meeresboden angekommen ist
und aus Prag ist mir jetzt vor dem
Gipfeltreffen unserer Korrespondent
ultra zugeschaltet guten Morgen Ulf mehr
als 40 europäische Länder kommen heute
erstmals zu einem Sondergipfel zusammen
das hat es so ja noch nie gegeben
darunter auch viele Balkanstaaten was
verspricht man sich von dieser neuen
politischen Gemeinschaft
also eigentlich will man hier einen
großen Traum beginnen in Prag etwas
träumen was es so noch nicht gegeben hat
quasi ein Europa XXL und das soll auch
eine Botschaft sein an die zwei anderen
großen weltblöcke nämlich Amerika und
China das Europa stark ist und in sehr
grundsätzlichen Fragen bei allen
Verschiedenheiten die man sonst hat doch
auch einig ist und die grundsätzliche
Frage und das ist die Botschaft die von
Prag ausgehen soll von diesem Europa XXL
ist dass man den Krieg in der Ukraine
nicht akzeptiert dass man das Verhalten
von Putin nicht akzeptiert und es soll
dann ein Familienfoto geben und das ist
quasi das Signal nach Moskau wir stehen
zusammen wenn man ein bisschen dichter
an dieses Familienfoto rangeht sieht man
natürlich die Risse und die
Schwierigkeiten dieses Traums das sind
Länder wie die Türkei die sehr
eigenwillig sind wenig mit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu tun haben und
gerade in Sachen Putin ein sehr eigenen
Kurs fahren und es sind auch Länder
eingeladen wie Armenien und
Aserbaidschan die momentan Krieg also es
ist ein großer Traum aber trotzdem weiß
man auch hier in Prag es gibt noch
keinen Grund wirklich zu schwärmerisch
zu werden es ist ein erster Versuch das
Thema Sicherheit wird ja auch ganz oben
auf der Agenda stehen und haben wir es
gerade auch im Beitrag gehört die
Großmächte USA und Russland liefern sich
ja schon längst ein Wettrüsten in den
Tiefen der Meere kann Europa da
überhaupt noch mithalten seine
unterwasser-infrastruktur zu sichern
wir erleben ja jetzt diese
sprichwörtliche Zeiten wenn du diese
zeitenwände findet eben auch am
Meeresboden statt Europa hat schon die
letzten Jahre sich immer wieder mit dem
Thema Sicherheit der Infrastruktur
beschäftigt aber es war wohl mehr ein
Expertenthema als wirklich ein Thema für
Politiker das muss man jetzt ernst
nehmen was man hier wahrscheinlich
anfangen wird ist über ein
Sicherheitskonzept nachzudenken am Ende
wird man mehr Geld ausgeben für Rüstung
eben auch für unterwasserrüstung wie ist
das zum Beispiel auch jetzt schon in
Deutschland gibt mit dem 100 Milliarden
Paket aber es ist nicht nur ein
europäisches Problem sondern wie das
Wort schon sagt in einer vernetzten Welt
spielen die Amerikaner eine große Rolle
und da kann eben Europa und Amerika sehr
sehr gut zusammenarbeiten man muss da
ein bisschen nationale Egoismen aufgeben
weil man auch Daten austauschen will
aber wenn man mehr zusammenarbeitet mehr
investiert in die Sicherheit dann kriegt
man auch mehr Schutz totalen Schutz wird
es nicht geben wenn es ein Angreifer
gibt wie gesagt der vielleicht ist
wirklich alles einzusetzen und sich
dabei auch selber weh zu tun wird es
sehr sehr schwer sein diese Lebensadern
unter Wasser zu schützen vielen Dank für
deine Einschätzung und du wirst den
Gipfel ja auch heute weiterhin noch
begleiten bis später